we're about to reveal the winner of the
masked finger and that winner is let's
jump right in to season two is right
around the corner how the celebrity's
been picked at rehearsals been started
what can you tease us with uh I've been
told that we were pretty packed I mean I
heard that the phones are ringing off
the hook of people who want to be on the
show it's the number one show on
television so I think they had a good
time booking it this season I had the
costumes and even more elaborate here
like last season we had 12 performance I
had we got 16 now and I hear there's
like an egg like that's like somebody
gonna be dressed in an egg
that's a little crazy I'm not allowed to
know any of that stuff which is really
the joy of it I mean if we know nothing
then we get to enjoy it with everybody
at home at the same time and everybody's
tweeting and trying to figure it out so
I think that it's better the less we
know the better I do know that we've 16
contestants this time versus 12 which is
good yeah a breakfast item and you know
I heard that because the season the
first season was so successful that's so
many I think every celebrity is a
celebrity but what they call a list
celebrities have glamour to be part of
season two I think you're gonna see
people on the show that like oh my god I
can't leave they're doing this show
that's what I think people are gonna say
about season two I know nothing I'm the
dumbest judge on the messenger and my
prediction the only thing I can predict
in season two I will be even dumber I
literally would be like great song couch
you know wonderful wonderful Aria chair
you know I mean you'll just see me with
the guesses will be more erratic more
off the mark and that's the ken Jeong
guarantee you could tell I'm taking it
so seriously they hired me for my
laser-like focus we're pretty much
big-time we're gonna ride this way for
as long as we can with a whole bunch of
gratitude right I'm riding it on the
gratitude train wave are you
basketball player Britney Spears now
tell me the the season one there was
such an intense secrecy behind the whole
thing are there any special measurements
that keep season two which secret are
the hoodies coming back
yeah the hoodies are definitely coming
back the the Secret Service as we call
it escorting people in and off of the
lot and I think it's bum and I think we
have a good time we're keeping that
secret and I even tell them don't tell
me and I'm you know the host / producer
and I still don't wanna knock because I
want that element of surprise the same
way the audience do I think that is
incredible I think it drives so much
excitement with this whole thing all the
secrecy of it absolutely I think that's
it's a guessing game for the entire
nation at the end of the day so and
everybody to be able to play you know in
primetime television is a lot of fun I
have to take extra measurements because
now they'll be eyes people who are big
fans of the show
I get DMS all the time you should put
this person on you should put that
person on and it's not even my decision
so I think the investment of the fans is
gonna mean that they'll have to take
even higher precaution there he measures
to make sure nobody knows who it is
season 2 for mass singer is a game of
Thrones lockdown secrets you guys it's
amazing they said it might be in a
different studio they keep everything
really really airtight like like I say
even the contestants representatives and
agents they're all wearing masks behind
the scenes it's crazy because you you
don't want anything leaked and that yes
I security is going to be even more
because of you know the the popularity
of the show I can guarantee you this
like security will be even tighter it'll
be even more yeah it will the access
will be even more even even more
restricted yeah I guarantee you that and
but I think it's gonna it's gonna be a
bigger and better season that's what I
predict you
you
[Music]